the traps that Kevin sets for the wet
Bandits at the end of the movie all seem
like delightfully funny pranks when
you're a kid but as an adult it's easy
to see the many ways they could have
resulted in death both criminals take
some serious blows to their heads and
the rest of their bodies during the home
invasion sequence any one of which could
have proved lethal first there's the
iron dropped on Marv's face via the
laundry shoot to which Falls three
stories to hit him squarely in the
forehead that's enough for severe facial
trauma and bone fractures then there are
the paint cans both Bandits take to the
face which could have taken their heads
right off and let's not forget the
Crowbar that Marb used to whack Harry in
the chest which could have broken his
ribs punctured his lungs or pierced his
heart and that's not even taking into
account all the other injuries both men
likely suffered as a result of Kevin's
less lethal traps somehow we doubt that
the McAllister's VCRs and jewelry were
worth all of that you guys give up or
you're thirsty for more